as an example of a mean variance
calculation we will now consider the
continuous uniform random variable which
we have introduced a little earlier this
is the continuous analogue of the
discrete uniform for which we have
already seen formulas for the
corresponding mean and variance so let
us now calculate the mean or expected
value for the continuous case the mean
is defined as an integral that ranges
over the entire real line on the other
hand we recognize that the density is
equal to 0 outside the interval from A
to B and therefore there is going to be
no contribution to the integral from
those X's outside that interval this
means that we can integrate just over
the interval from A to B and inside that
interval the value of the density is 1
over B minus a we can carry out this
integration and find an answer equal to
a plus B over 2 which interestingly also
happens to be the same as in the
discrete case in fact we could find this
answer without having to run this
integration we could just recognize that
this PDF is symmetric around the mint
point of the interval and the midpoint
is a plus B over 2 we now continue with
what is involved in the calculation of
the expected value of the square of the
random variable using the expected value
rule this is the integral of x squared
times the density but because of the
same argument as before we only need to
integrate from A to B we can evaluate
this integral and the answer turns out
to be 1 over B minus a times B cube over
3 minus a cube over 3 the reason why
this cubic terms appear is that the
integral of the x squared function is X
cube divided by 3
now that we have this quantity available
we're ready to calculate the variance
using this alternative formula which as
we have often discussed usually provides
us a quicker way to carry out the
calculation we take this term insert it
here we take the square of this term
insert it here carry out some algebra
and eventually we find an answer which
is equal to B minus a squared over 12
and this is the formula for the variance
of a uniform random variable we can take
the square root of this expression to
find the standard deviation and the
standard deviation is going to be B
minus a divided by the square root of 12
a few observations first the formula
looks quite similar to the formula for
the variance that we had in the discrete
case except that in the discrete case we
have this extra additive factor of two
more interestingly and perhaps more
important is that the standard deviation
is proportional to the width of this
uniform the wider it is the larger the
standard deviation will be and this
conforms to our intuition that the
standard deviation captures the width of
a particular distribution and the
variance of course becomes larger when
the width is larger and as far as the
variance is concerned it increases with
the square of the length of the interval
over which we have our distribution